Recall that in one of our earlier lectures, we discussed memory consistency
model and the relationship of memory consistency model to cache
coherence, in the context of shared memory systems. Memory consistency model is
a contract between the application programmer and the
system. It answers the when question, that is, when a shared
memory location is modified by one processor, when, that is how soon, that
change is going to be made visible to other processes that have the same memory
location in their respective private caches. That's
the question that is being answered by
the memory consistency model. Cache coherence, on
the other hand, is answering the how question,
that is, how is the system, by system we mean the system software plus the
hardware working together, implementing the contract of
the memory consistency model? In other words, the
guarantee that has been made by the
memory consistency model, to the application programmer has
to be fulfilled by the cache coherence
mechanism. So coming back to writing a parallel
program, when accesses are made to the shared memory,
the underlying coherence mechanism has to ensure that all
the processes see the changes that are being made
to shared memory, commensurate with the memory consistency model.